Uh,
I'm Jonathan Rosenberg and I ran product
management here for 10 years and I
don't usually come and introduce
speakers, but, and it's special.
And so I came to tell you why
since 2002 when I joined Google,
my favorite days were
Mondays for 10 years.
Monday morning was Eric and Larry Staff
meeting and I was surrounded by smart
people with a mission that mattered.
And in the afternoon I would run my
staff meeting and my staff meeting was
Sundar and solar and Marissa.
And the second smartest was Jackie's
sister. Is this being recorded?
Susan, I love you. And in 2011,
when all of that ended and I
moved out of an operational role,
I thought I'd never have
exciting Mondays again.
Then Susan introduced me to Ann and I
started going to 23 and me's staff meeting
and helping over there. So
now on Mondays, once again,
I'm surrounded by smart people and I'm
in a company where the mission that
we're,
the mission matters,
bringing personalized medicine
to like make us healthier.
Like we care about being healthier.
So the mission is terrific.
The team is brilliant.
It's a little bit different because more
than half of the faces in the room are
women and the CEO is a woman
and Katie and Jessica are here.
Some of the people who are in
the staff meeting, in fact,
more than half of the faces in the
room are women. Even when I'm there,
I'm doing pretty well.
So rather than kind of go through
all the Yada Yada of a traditional
introduction, you know,
like an is special.
And she went to Yale and she spent 10
years doing like medicine and healthcare
investing and is very googley look at the
way she's dressed for her Google talk.
So listen to an listened to her vision,
listen to them talk and Jordan talk
about some of the great challenges that
she's faced,
building 23 and me and many of the
googly values that she's infused in this
wonderful company and an you're the reason
I get out of bed on Monday mornings.
I love you.
[inaudible]
okay,
I'll turn things over to Anna and Jordan.
All right. Can you guys hear me
okay? Thank you for joining us here.
Really appreciate it. And thank
you for joining us. Of course,
after an intro like that.
So I know he can't beat that.
So for the force 45,
50 minutes,
I'm going to go with the questions
that I took from the dory.
So thank you all first
mandatory questions.
And then for the last 10 minutes we'll
do mixture of live questions and dory
questions.
Um,
but I to start off first
with your relationship here
with Google and your story
that you were telling me
about you and the cafe.
Yeah. So I honestly, I've known
Google since the very earliest days.
It started in my sister's garage.
Um, so it was one of those things in,
in the early days we'd be doing dishes
and we could see Sergei and Larry coding
and like the other bedroom. And I
used to always say, it was like,
it's really weird that you have these
guys like just sitting in the other room
coning while we're doing dishes.
Like it was a really unusual, um,
so obviously I've spent a lot of time at
the company and I was saying how I'm 23
and me used to have an office,
I'm on the shore birds,
so just around the corner and we're, you
know, like we're a startup, we're scrappy.
And, um, so it was very apparent that,
you know, Google had a lot of food.
So we used to make our way over here.
And you know,
back when there was Burrito's
right downstairs, um,
there was a great burritos
and so they're easy to carry.
So I would walk over every other Thursday
and we'd have these team lunches and I
just get like 10 burritos.
And so I was walking out carrying like
my mom mind burritos and I opened the
door and I look, and it's Eric Schmidt
and Steve Jobs. Okay. And I was like,
oh, hi. Like, what are you
doing? And Eric's like, what
do you have to, I'm like,
oh, just getting lunch. And Steve had
just launched the iPhone and was like,
have you seen the iPhone? Do you want
to see it? I'm like, yeah, great.
So, um, so I've had a lot
of great experiences. Um,
I'm obviously in such a huge fan of
Google and a lot of ways it's had a huge
influence on 23 and me and I think a lot
of the values that I saw especially in
the early days have really
influenced how we run the company.
Now you were mentioning
about your values and 23,
me and you were telling
me about your role,
your relationship with your grandmother
and your experience with the healthcare
system. Can you talk a
little about it? Yeah, yeah.
Um,
you know,
I think so as a background I used to
invest in healthcare companies and um,
you know,
health is a really complicated industry
and it's not necessarily always doing
the right thing for the consumer.
And I used to always complain
like I actually the last fun,
the last Hedge Fund I was at was a
fun that we nicknamed Death Watch.
And we used to just short everything
cause it's really easy to predict failures
and biotech, but it's hard to
predict successes. And so I was like,
kind of just like this really negative,
like everything sucks in healthcare.
It's all bad. It's all failing.
It's like all about like,
how do I just take
advantage of the consumer?
And I remember Larry Turning
to me one day and he's like,
and you're either part of the solution
or you're part of the problem right now.
You're part of the problem. Um,
I was like, oh, like that's true.
Like in some ways I was a good
slap of like, you have to, if you,
when you see problems you need
to do something to change it.
And one thing that we've always,
my family has always been really
passionate about is healthcare.
And part of this came from the fact
that my mother, um, was, you know,
she was very poor growing up and she
had a little brother and when he was 18
months old,
he got into a bottle of aspirin and he
ate that bottle of aspirin and he was
clearly lethargic. They took them
from hospital, a hospital hospital,
and my mom was five at the time. And, um,
they were refused treatment because
they couldn't show proof of payment.
They finally got some hospital
to take him and they took him.
And then when my grandmother
called in the morning,
they said he was dead and it had a huge
impact on my mom as it would have on any
family. And my mom at this time
was like, you know, very clear.
If you don't take care of yourself,
no one will and you have to be
responsible for your healthcare.
So when I pulled my Kaiser
medical records at some point, um,
my sisters and I discovered
that our records actually
had an asterisk at the top
that said,
as all of us in pediatrics know,
this mother can be very irrational at
times. And as Jonathan has had some,
some lovely times also working
with my mom, my mom is a force.
Um, and especially in health care, like
we routinely get fired from doctors.
We routinely or told people
don't want to work with us.
And I think it's one thing I've learned
is like in some ways good healthcare
comes to those who complain and
you have to be really proactive.
So it was one of those things like we
were always a super proactive family, um,
you know,
understanding our health.
And it was one of the things that I
think really bothered me when I was
investing in healthcare is I realized how
much the system is not set up for your
success. Like no one
makes money if you, um,
if you live to be a hundred and you never
are sick, no one makes money, you know,
and healthcare is 18% of our GDP.
Like clearly lots of people are
making money off you being sick,
but as a real problem.
And so a lot of my passion for 23 and
me when I started the company came from
how much I said like I
want to do something that's
genuinely right that allows
people to be active in their health and
proactive the way my mother has always
been proactive for me and that she's
taught me to be proactive with my health.
Can you talk about the first
years of you building 23 me,
the challenges you went
through. So we got lucky. Um,
you know,
I think a lot of founders
like in something like
Sergei and Larry used to say
this, like they got lucky, they
have the right place right time. Um,
I happened to be,
when I was investing in on Wall Street,
I happened to realize
like genetic information.
It was suddenly cheap to get access to
a broad amount of information on your
genome. And um, you know,
I was really lucky noticing like one
you could get suddenly individuals could
access to your genome and then there was
this whole convergence of like web 2.0
like there's going to be social networks
and you're going to find each other.
And it was like hot. It was so
interesting and it was my space and um,
and it suddenly realized,
um,
one of the things that's a big issue in
healthcare is there's a lack of data.
So I like routinely my sister other sister
does nutrition research and routinely
you look at those studies and it's
like 200 patients here, 200 here.
And My dad who's a particle physicist
would be like anyone who knows about
statistics. So it was like you
can't find anything in that.
It's like you need lots of data.
And clearly the Google world had taught
me like the value of like lots of data
and what you can do.
Um,
so I got lucky sort of with this
idea of why do I need Stanford?
Why do I need Pfizer to go
and do all this research?
I can just allow all these people to learn
about their genome. Like it's so cool.
Learn about your genetics.
And then we're going to bring everyone
together in this whole new research model
is going to be like crowd sourcing.
We're going to have the world's data.
I don't need Stanford and Pfizer
and all these other people.
I don't want you to be a human subject.
I want you to be alive,
participant excited and research.
Um,
so we have this idea really marrying like
this idea of cool technology with like
this concept of like health, you know,
web 2.0 and we launched the company.
And, um, you know, initially
I had this enthusiasm.
I think genetics is so cool.
Like I think there's nothing
cooler than the idea is like,
you have a genetic code.
Everyone in this room is 99.5% the same.
Yet we clearly have all this
diversity and we don't understand it.
Like it's like the, it's, it's
like, it's a code. Like how does it,
how do people sleep at night? It's so
interesting and we don't understand it.
And so, um, so I have this enthusiasm, um,
but I started to realize that the rest
of the world's not quite as passionate
about genetics as I am. Um, and so
we launched and we had, uh, you know,
we had this big spit parties,
we had all kinds of press. Um,
and then we sold probably a third,
a thousand kits the first day.
And then we were selling
like 15 to 20 kids a day.
And as everyone realizes
like 15 to 20 kids a day,
if not a lot of money
like that is that is not,
not even going to be a ramen profitable
company like that is, um, that,
that's rough. Um, so it
made me realize like,
we have to do a lot to help people
understand like what our genetics,
like most people, um, like really smart
people would come to me and be like, oh,
I don't want to know my DNA. I don't
want to know the day I'm going to die.
And I was like, if I can tell
you the day you're going to die,
charge you a lot more.
Like [inaudible] I was like,
no, it's like risk, like, and you realize
like most people don't understand risk.
And um,
so the thing that I've been lucky with
is I have a team of people who join 23
and me because they're really passionate.
And you know, my love for science,
like I said, my father's a
particle physicist and as kids,
my sisters and I grew up always like
realizing like we tell people like,
oh my dad is like, he studies
neutrinos, he's searching for mass.
And people were like, what?
Like what is he doing? And,
and I just realized like I in some ways,
like it always bothered me.
I think physics is the most
beautiful science out there,
but like most people don't understand it.
And I also like in genetics is similar.
Like I really didn't want the fate that
my father went through with physics of
like, you know, lack of
funding and all this.
Like I wanted the average individual to
like see the beauty of the d of Dna and
see it within their own lens
and capture this idea of like,
we're all most interested in ourselves.
And so your DNA is really
interesting to you. Um,
so the people I hired in those early days,
a lot of them are still at the company
and they're really passionate about this
idea that like, you want people to like,
you want people to see that beauty.
And um, and so I'm lucky
because the fact that like,
it was hard those first years, I'm
like, we didn't have huge sales.
It didn't deter people
because of their, like, again,
scientists are used to failure. Like,
wow, you know, we just have to try this.
We have to try that. We have to like
try other strategies. So it was,
um, you know, I'm lucky with that.
And also the science, you know,
one of the things that we did with the
company that was unusual is we weren't
excessively marketing
because we decided like,
we wanted to really make sure
that we have the science down.
Before we did a lot of marketing
and the one marketing thing we did,
this is another funny story.
Um, surrogate at this time,
I don't know who's been here for how
long Sergei was really interested in
Zeppelins blimps. Um, and so there was a,
there was a Zeppelin for awhile and
Sergei didn't want to stick like a Google
stickler on it. So he's like, I don't
know, he could put 23 me on it. So we put,
cause he wanted to sell advertising on it.
So we put 23 me sticker on it and it
got a lot of press that there was like a
giant Zeplin flying around town. Um,
like tech crunch had all these articles.
So that was like my one attempt before
we had a marketing team. I had the blimp.
Um,
I'm no longer part of the marketing team,
but we really focus like as a
company to in those early days,
we recognize like we have no business,
that we don't have a scientific foundation
and that the core of the company,
like I needed to win over the scientists
and make sure that they understand what
we're doing and that are a pre,
that they're supportive of what we're
doing before I go big and start going on
TV and started advertising.
And in some ways that also
really benefited the company
because when there was
controversy,
I never had to worry about my core.
Like I always knew the foundation
of the company was really strong.
I didn't have to worry.
Like I understood it was
misunderstood and all these ways,
but scientifically I was always
solid and I knew that. Excellent.
And we proposed a blimp idea.
Did you have to bring it up to your
board or something? No, I think,
I think I just did it,
you know,
that's the beauty of a startup is like
you don't even think about these things.
I don't know, like I just,
I just put it up there. No,
I mean my board has always been,
um,
pretty small and I just
like, I, you know, again,
when you're a 10 person company,
you're a 15 person company,
you just like do things all the time
that are kind of crazy. Like this.
When we launched our spit party in
New York, we had Barry Diller, um,
host and like Rupert Murdoch,
like all these people host the spit party.
And it was on the cover of the style
section on the Sunday style section.
And I remember like,
see like people like Eric Lander,
like serious scientists who are like,
it is so disrespectful to have
science on like the style section,
like this is not appropriate.
And, um, and I was like, no,
like more people read the science sec
where more people read the style section,
they read science Tuesday,
like this is great.
So we were always kind of doing things,
um, that were a little bit different.
Like we wanted to do things not to say
like the blimp, but the blimp was fun. Um,
but we wanted to do things that were
going to be atypical of what the
traditional scientific world does.
Cause like most people are not out
meeting New England Journal in Science
magazine. Like we want to
bring science to the masses.
Excellent.
Um,
when I had been Horowitz here and we
talked about the struggle that CEOs go
through where it's just a
really challenging time. Yeah.
And you have to really fight
through it to survive. Um,
it seemed like the struggle for you
as during that whole FDA period.
Can you talk to us about that and then
also what kept you going during that time?
You don't, I think, um, I think I've
had two struggles in the company,
so the FDA one was clearly,
um,
an important one and it was in some ways
it was the most public and it forced us
to really change our
strategy. And um, you know,
we got what happens,
we got the letter and we got the FDA
warning letter on a Friday and I was at a
team offsite where in a strategy offsite
we were like talking about like we have
massive growth who are really excited.
We were going for a million people. Um,
and my assistant at the time texted
me and she said, you ought, um, uh,
a special, the like the, the FDA is
trying to curry or something to you.
And I was like, well,
don't sign for it. Um, and
I was like, I already did. I was
like, aw, why did you sign for it? Um,
and then I was like, bring it to me
and, um, and then we read it, you know,
and we were like, we'd gotten a
lot of warning letters in the past.
Like we were kind of used to it by
that. And we're like, ah, you know,
whenever we got him all the time.
Um,
but this one was like a
lot more serious. Um, and,
and to be honest,
like silicon valley is not known
for its interaction with regulators.
Um, so it, I was like, I think
we were relatively naive.
Like I get this question a lot,
like,
where are we just like so arrogant and
we'd kind of given the finger to the FDA
or where we just incompetent. And I think
it's something we were just uneducated.
Like we, um, like it took me a while
even after getting that letter,
cause then it was made public
on Monday morning and, um,
and people would read it and
they're like, wow, this is like,
like this is probably one of the most
serious warning letters that's ever been
put out there.
And it was actually one of the former
heads of the FDA who called me and was
like an like, they're not messing
around, like you have to stop. Um,
and, and it was, uh, it was,
it definitely, it halted
a lot within the company.
And that first week I think I just spent
the entire week in my pajamas calling
lawyers. Like I just, I didn't move
from my desk. I just called. And for me,
I've always been very data driven.
Like I just wanted all the information.
So it was just pulling information like,
what do I do?
And we've always historically been
really good at finding loopholes. Um,
so for instance, in New York
where we were not allowed to sell,
we discovered that,
um,
it wasn't that you weren't allowed to
sell and you just weren't allowed to
physically spit in the state and was like,
that's great.
People Been Spit in New Jersey. Um, and
so we'd found kind of this loophole,
like customers used to have to attest
that they had not physically spat in the
state. Um, and so I spent a lot of
time figuring out like, what's the,
like how do I work around this?
And to be honest,
like one of the work arounds today is
that you put what we call sort of a doc in
the box. Like you have a telemedicine
doctor where you just can call,
uh, or sorry. It's just like they
are kind of like on the backend.
Like you not even necessarily
see it and they order it for you.
And when you have that you
can kind of circumvent,
you can become a
laboratory developed test.
And there was one regulator
in particular who, um,
I met with and she goes,
you know,
and like what you're trying to do
is fundamentally really disruptive.
Like you're trying to allow consumers
to get direct access to care without
having to go through a medical provider.
And if you succeed in that,
you can really have an impact,
a real positive impact on the system.
But doing that as not a
work around it's hard work.
Like either you decide you want to put
your head down and you want to just like
really get that work done or you find
if you want to sell this company in a
couple of years, like you do this work
around and you're just like, whatever,
you're just circumventing the system but,
but you can change the system.
And that conversation had a huge impact.
And I said, I said, look like, well,
I'm in it for the next, you
know, I'm in it for life,
so I'm willing to do the hard
work. And you know, it took us, um,
you know,
from that moment,
it was a couple of years before we
actually got our first approval.
And the way we did it, people
always ask like, what'd you do?
And in some ways when you're
in a hole like that, um,
no one like the regulators
did not trust us.
And so the way that you win back trust,
especially with an organization
like the FDA is they speak in data.
Like you guys probably all
work with people who like,
like they understand data,
like show us the data and then we
can make a decision. And so we did,
um, you know, one of the other
things I learned with the FDA to, um,
I always tell my kids this,
I learned obedience. Um,
I learned that when you go to the DMV,
you know,
you don't argue about standing in line
or you don't argue about doing a vision
test, you just do it. You don't try to
say like, oh, I just had one last week.
Here's the report. Um, you just
do it. And similar to the FDA,
you have to recognize,
they sometimes know more than you do
because they're seeing the whole picture
and you just do it. You like, you
negotiate, but you do the pro.
You do what they ask you to do. And, um,
in some ways by showing that we could be
obedient and we could follow directions
and that we had the data to prove it.
Um,
and we had to change a lot of things
within the company to be a regulated
company. And there's a lot, um,
that we had to do from an engineering
and product and design perspective to
document how everything's happens. Um,
and so again, it's been a ton of work,
but it's fundamentally made us a much
better company because our processes are
much stronger. Um, so it was, um,
it definitely was rough
and there was a lot of, um,
controversy within the company about
whether or not this was the right path.
And I think as a leader of the company,
when the most important things is to
do is to allow controversy, you know,
allow people to have to voice their
questions. Like invoice it. Like,
I think Google is one thing I
learned with Google. It's like,
you want to let people debate.
Debate is really good. Um,
but once you make a decision, everyone's
on board. And if you don't agree,
then it's not the right
place. Um, but we had,
we have a fair amount of
debate and before, like we,
I encourage that as a leader.
I encourage that debate.
And then once we make a decision and you
can set a vision for the future and say,
look, like we're, we're trying to
fundamentally change the system,
would like trying to empower
consumers like my next day. Like,
why do you have to go and get a
doctor's order to get a blood test?
Do you always need it for
our prescription? Like
all these, like the whole,
you know, um, patriarchal system.
Like why do you actually need, like,
why do you need this physician or medical
involvement before you can actually
get some of this information?
So we're really out for
that bigger picture of like
trying to change the system.
So for your current offerings,
you offer the ancestry test and
then you can get the health test
correct. So for two years,
we, um, we just kind of, we,
all we did was offer ancestry and
we focused on pulling out the health
information we've gotten. We have three
FDA approvals now or authorizations.
So we have carrier status.
Um, we have genetic,
which is things like cystic fibrosis.
We have genetic health risks,
which is things like Parkinson's
disease and Alzheimer's. Um,
and then we have now the
breast cancer variance,
the three most common in Jewish women,
um,
or Jewish individuals that
we test for those variance.
Um,
are you playing offer more extensive
testing like such as metabolic imbalances
and enzymes? Like what like um,
cause I have a Google or asking,
oh, it was family members
has chronic pain and I think
no, I mean we're focusing
on DNA. Like if it's,
if it's a genetic variant of
a task that we could detect,
like we're focusing just on DNA right now.
Um,
so we definitely think about partnerships
that we could do that would have, um,
you know,
especially anything that we could do
that's potentially at home where we could
allow you to have at home collection
and think about other tests that you're
getting.
For right now it's just focused.
Like we're definitely looking to expand
that, the tasks that we're offering. Um,
but everything will be
just based on genetics.
Excellent. Um, so given the large corpus
of data you're putting together, are you,
how have you been able to use this
like PR for promoting cures or new
developments in the field?
We do.
So that was part of the hypothesis of
the company is that if I collect all of
this information and all of this data,
can I then more effectively
make discoveries,
academic research discoveries as well
as can I translate this information into
drug therapeutics? So the drug industry,
again, when I was running this,
this one I was investing in companies
and running that fund that I called Death
Watch.
Um,
part of the reason why I
could do something like
that is statistically 90% of
everything fails in biotech.
So if 90% of everything fails,
like you just short everything,
like there's like you don't have
to do that much math for like,
it was just like you can
predict failures. Um, so in,
in the drug discovery business,
it's the Pharma lobbying group is the
only group I know that like would actively
promote every year how it's more
and more expensive to create a drug.
So like when I started investing it
with $700 million to make a drug,
and today it's close to $3 billion.
So it's only getting worse.
So the idea with all this data is can I
in some ways more effectively use this
data to,
to translate it into drug hypotheses
and then do I have a higher success rate
for making therapeutics.
So we are doing that now.
We hired Richard Scheller who was the
head of research and development at
Genentech. Um, we have over 10
programs in development now.
We've been doing this now for three years.
We work with a ton of Pharma partnerships.
Um, so we are actively trying to say,
can you turn data into
curative therapeutics?
So we are actively working on that
now. And my hope is like, again,
because we're a scientific team,
like I can say this and I
have a hypothesis and I,
but I can't make any claims yet,
but my hope is in 10 years I can
come back and say like, look,
here's our success rate
compared to industry averages.
And we believe that that success rate
will come because we're starting with
something that's data
driven based on genetics,
possibly a new business model
for the users of 23 meals.
So like if I provide you with health data,
it leads to some type of cure.
It's hard to translate.
Um,
the reality with drug development
is that drug development is,
um, it's a really long
and complicated process.
So at what point in time
can I identify that?
Like your participation
made such a huge difference.
So what we tried to do is say,
like we learning from our customers.
So for instance,
in depression we did a study where we
had 400,000 customers participate and
thanks to the participation
of so many individuals. Um,
we were able to make discoveries in
depression and then you potentially can
analyze all those genetic
variants and say these are these,
this is one where we think this is
potentially a druggable target. Um,
so it's really hard to do the
micro attribution to say, hey,
these individuals and plus it's
like a 10 to 15 year process.
So you might come back and
say, hey, 15 years later what,
what we have found is what
people really care about. Um,
like we had a community of individuals
actually have someone from Google
actually who we worked with who had
sarcoma. She's like, I don't care.
What I care about is a cure.
Like I have sarcoma.
Like I have a lethal disease.
Like I would like to live. And um,
I find people with serious illnesses
like that. They care about two things.
Like does this impact my children
and I would like to survive.
But me coming to you and saying,
here's a check for $100.
I'm sorry you're going to die
soon. Like is not like it. Like,
we want to do the right thing
and everything at 23. And me, um,
all of our decisions that we make are
about what is in the best interest of our
customers. And my customer is always
the individuals who signed up.
And so we always think about everything
from the perspective of like,
you just participated in research.
Like what is it that is in the best
interest for you? And if you tell me,
for instance, that you have, you have
migraines and you have, um, you know, uh,
you know,
crones w we,
it's our job then to help you figure out
the best ways that you can participate
in research or for us to actually
move those things forward,
to have some kind of impact in your life.
And then you could
potentially help be a control.
There might be somebody here who's
like, oh, I'm high, you know,
I have a family history of prostate
cancer and we have depression.
And you can say, I can be
a control for you. And,
and that way everybody is
actually helping each other.
So it's hard to then point to well
who exactly is responsible because the
reality is really a community asset.
That makes sense. Um, for the survey
aspect, when you're a member of 23 and me,
they ask you questions.
Sometimes you probably might
get data that is just erroneous.
Like do you use like multiple
data points to figure out?
We do. One of the things we found, so
this is a good example in um, we asked,
we put out questions to our customers.
So we ask,
we have a pretty comprehensive survey
that we first ask everyone to take. Um,
and sometimes you have to refine the
question. So in this day and age,
everybody thinks they have celiac disease.
Um,
but very few people have actually
gotten a biopsy. So if I ask people,
have you had celiac disease,
the genetic associations known,
previously known to occur with that
don't replicate. But if I ask you,
do you have celiac and have
you had a biopsy to confirm it,
then I can actually hit the replication.
I like get the,
I can find in the genetic studies
the known the known findings.
So we do find that we have to triangulate
questions quite a bit. Um, again,
it's one of the things that I learned
from Google and sort of like big data
people is that it's much better to have
like massive amounts of dirty data.
And, um, for us, you know, we
have now 5 million customers,
we have over 1.5 billion data
points on those customers. Um,
we have the potential to do a lot of
research. It's without a doubt there's,
it's not perfect. Not
Everybody, um, um, you know,
reports everything perfectly,
but it's pretty good. And
if I ask you for instance,
like, do you have epilepsy, you can
probably report that pretty accurately.
And so what we find is that
there's almost, um, um, you know,
it's, it's almost a false truth that like,
oh, a clinical trial is perfect data.
It was one thing I learned when I was on
Wall Street is how much when you have a
multicenter trial,
if you have 20 different centers trying
to diagnose a partial response in cancer
is really controversial. So, um,
a lot of aspects of medicine like defining
a phenotype is controversial and in
some ways the best thing that 23
knee does is we have it all in a very
standardized form and we always have the
ability to go back to our customers and
ask and say, okay, if
you said you had asthma,
now we're going to go back and ask
you and ask you more about like your
medications. You're
like, when does it occur?
And you can start to weed out
when something doesn't look real.
No, I'm sure people have
seen the information and they
might have overreacted or
whatnot. Yeah. Um,
have you considered like any connecting
23 meter like genetic counseling or
providing people information on how to
talk about these results with the primary
care physician? Right, right.
We do actually connect
people. Um, so we don't,
the main thing that we tried to do that
we feel really strongly about is that
health care insurance,
like a physician involvement or
genomic counselor is up to you.
And so we never used that as a bottleneck
for access to your information.
But if you find out, for instance,
that you're positive for breast cancer,
the Brca mutation,
you know,
you want to follow up with a
physician or a genetic counselor.
And so we have had partnerships in the
past and we look at doing that more and
more as where you, we might at
least give you advice like, hey,
here's resources where you can go to.
Um, but we don't ever, we feel, again,
philosophically as a company,
we feel really strongly that it's
never a bottleneck for access,
but we do provide resources for
people so they know how to follow up.
Um, for my friend who have
convinced to try use 23 and me,
some of them have told me,
well, the reason why I want
to do it, it's because of,
I know that I could be susceptible to
a heart attack or some other health
problem. I'd rather like be
left not knowing the situation.
And then I've heard people who have said,
well,
now that I know I could possibly have
a health issue and my stress me out or
something. Have you done any research
about like the psychological aspect? Yeah,
we have,
um,
we have done a lot of research
and actually one of the
best studies that was out
there,
there was a guy named Robert Green who
is at Harvard and he did the original
studies on Alzheimer's and looking at
people as a series of studies called
reveal where he was able to see that
people like Alzheimer's is one of the more
extreme. So people find out they're
genetically high risk for Alzheimer's. Um,
what do they do? And he found that
initially there is anxiety. Um,
but after three months
you returned to baseline.
And for a lot of these individuals, they
already know there's a family history.
So for instance, for people who have,
um, again, the Alzheimer's variant,
if there's a high genetic risk factor,
like you probably have someone in your
family network who's had Alzheimer's.
So you know that you have some kind
of genetic risk factor already.
So what we find,
and for me the story of genetics,
the reason why I was so interested in
genetics is that you do have genes and
environment. So your genetics are
not, unless it's Huntington's,
like it's not deterministic.
It's not 100% you have this whole
beautiful world of your environment.
And so to me, the environment
is your responsibility.
Like that's what you can do.
Like you can do something every single
day to influence your environment.
So without a doubt there's [inaudible],
there's people who are genetically high
risk for Alzheimer's but they don't get
it.
And so why,
like that's one thing I'm
really passionate about
personally is looking at who
are the people who are
genetically risk for diseases,
who never get them and what was it in
their environment. And the reality is,
I goes back to some of the
original premise of the company.
Like one of the issues is like being
really healthy doesn't make money in the
system,
but 23 and me is really uniquely set up
in large in many ways to do research on
prevention. So it's one of the things
we're really passionate about is like,
look at the people who have Alzheimer's
and say, okay, is it interval training?
Is it like extreme exercise?
Like,
what is it that really has an influence
on your life and can we then help people
take responsibility on a daily basis to
try and actually help prevent diseases?
Everyone knows or everyone gets
sick at something like every,
like it's one of the things I always say,
people would say,
oh you're just going to have all
these healthy people. And I was like,
there's no such thing as a healthy person.
Everyone has something.
It's like it could be depression, it
could be migraines, it could be, you know,
stomach problems. Silly. I like anything,
there's no such thing as
someone who like 100% healthy.
So like for me part of it was
like helping people realize, um,
that like your health is really a
sum of your actions every day. Like,
and for us to be able to do that research
on like what is it in our environment
that we can really do? And the thing
that I take most pride in is like,
rather than us creating
any kind of anxiety or,
or other issues is what people do is like,
people are looking to, to make change.
Like people get their genetic information
and it's something in black and white
and then they're looking to make
a change. And I think the, the,
the number one disservice
at the healthcare industry
has right now is there's
not great support for changing your
behavior and people don't know how.
So often like we heard this, um,
with Alzheimer's, I had one doctor,
he could stood up at a conference
and complain. He goes, you know,
one of the biggest problems with 23
and me is you generate non billable
questions and um,
and the reality is like you show up when
you say I'm genetically high risk for
Alzheimer's and the like will come
back when you have Alzheimer's.
Like that's what we do.
Um, but the reality,
like when you think about where do you
go to prevent the number one place where
people go to prevent any kind of
disease in this country is realistically
Walmart.
Like it's a behavior,
like the average American goes to Walmart
three times a week or in this day and
age is going to be Amazon. Like
it's, it's, it's, you're shopping,
it's your consumer. It's like how
you are living your life every day.
And one of the things I really try to
home in on on our customers a hammer and
our customers is like your health is
a sum of what you do every single day.
And so again,
going back to the gene and environment
pitch like it is like you can control
your environment,
you can't control your genes but
you can control your environment.
And we are trying to make
those discoveries about
what in your environment is
potentially going to influence your genes.
The most
people who are fearful about putting
their information into the system.
One thing explain hearing is how do I
know that my genetic information will not
fall into the wrong hands. Like recently
we heard about another genetic company,
I guess they were hacked or whatnot.
So for someone who's fearful about
sharing information to 23 and be like,
what would you say to them? It was
one of the things early on, um,
for people who are privacy.
We spent a lot of time with
privacy experts in the early days.
And it was one of the
things I conclude early on,
it was like for people who are like
really care, I was like, don't do it.
Just don't like spend the time
like get comfortable with it. Um,
you know what we can do as a company.
Um,
cause there's a lot of irrational fears
and that's why we used to say that as a
company we have to do everything
we can to protect privacy.
Like there's fundamentally
no business model.
Like I'm totally dependent on
my customer's participation
and their trust in
what to do the research and to do
the types of things we want to do.
So I have no business model if I can't
protect the privacy of my customers. Um,
so we do a lot like from a database
infrastructure, how we set it up, um,
to even the fact that it's not a
swab. It is, uh, two mils of saliva.
We reject samples if we
don't get enough saliva.
So you can't be accidentally swapped
while you're sleeping. Like it's a lot,
you'll never drool that
much in your sleep. Um,
and so we've set up the company and
also we don't have what we call it,
like the legal chain of custody.
So if you order five kits,
I have no idea if you spat or if you
gave them a way to five random people in
this room. So I don't have the direct
tracing back to two individuals. Um,
from our terms of service as
well. We've, we've, you know,
specifically said it's not to be
used for law enforcement. Um, and,
and we've set up the company in such a
way to make sure that it is really hard.
Like we have not gotten a subpoena on
this. We've put out a transparency report.
Um, we would do everything we
can to fight a subpoena. Um,
it hasn't happened for us, but those
are the types of things where, um,
for people who are really, really
concerned, like just don't do it. Um,
for people who like are comfortable
with being on the web, um,
we do everything we can to
protect their privacy. Um,
and one of the core elements,
like one of the leading privacy
experts when the things he taught me,
it was like,
look in what privacy people really
want is they want choice and they want
transparency.
They want to know.
So if you're a 23 and me and you
don't want to share your data,
like don't share it and we have,
we have to respect that.
So if you don't want to participate in
research, you don't have to participate.
If you don't want to share your genetic
data with me, don't share it. Um,
if you want to share it with, you
know, five people in this room,
we allow you to share it.
So we've given you a lot of controls
and that's also one of the things that's
relatively atypical and health care.
Like if you wanted to share
your medical record with me,
it would be almost impossible.
Um,
so we do a lot to make sure that we're
like empowering people to have that
privacy. Um, and then have also the
ability to, to compare when they want.
One of the things that I just
say about there is like when,
when people in general talk about privacy,
um,
like if I picked anyone
randomly in this room,
like I'm sure your genetics would be
really interesting and I would love to see
them. Um, but your bank account
is always much more interesting.
And so from a desire to hack in to,
you know,
one or the other,
your bank is just a lot more interesting.
And so when I look at like everyone's Dna,
um,
and when I think about privacy, it's,
it's significantly less on a mass area.
But what you see is like within a family,
people will say,
I want to see if my
brother was really related.
Like it is he really my full brother.
Um,
and so you get some of those intro
family privacy questions rather than
necessarily a broad sweep.
No. On a policy level,
are there things at 23,
are there policies or legislation that
23 me is backing from the federal level?
That's,
we,
back in the early days,
there was something called the genetic
information nondiscrimination act and it
passed unanimously
bipartisan. Um, it is a,
it's the, it prevents, it
prevents insurance companies,
health insurance companies and employers
from using genetic information for
discrimination. So that was a
huge step for us. It does not,
it leaves health insurance
outside. Um, I'm sorry,
it leaves life insurance outside.
Um, but that was, that was, uh,
a pretty significant step forward in
terms of giving federal protection to help
people feel comfortable that they
can keep their genetic information to
themselves,
ruin the life insurance aspect is or
other legislation that's going to be pros
in the future.
I haven't seen anything. Um, now,
and it's interesting to me because it's
been 10 years and there hasn't really
been any movement or any interest
necessarily from life insurance on it. Um,
the reality we find too is genetic
information is complicated.
Like it's not well understood
yet. So exactly how would
you, like, we already know,
like some of the biggest risk factor
is obesity, smoking. Um, you know,
like those are, those are the biggest
out there. So other than like, okay,
you're genetically high
risk for a condition that we
just don't fully understand
yet.
Um,
like I'm much more optimistic about
like in my dream world that we would
actually have insurance. Insurance
companies are embracing it and says, okay,
you're genetically high risk for
a blood clot and you're a woman.
You potentially are higher risk
than for miscarriage and pregnancy.
We're going to try to like mitigate those
rest by, you know, x number of measures.
Like there's things I wish the healthcare
system would adopt with genetic
information rather than being reactive.
But that hasn't really happened yet.
So going forward for the next 10
years of 23 and me like where,
where do you see yourself as a company?
I think,
um,
one of the most interesting things I see
happening finally is that there is an
interesting world of virtual
health care. So you know, like Vic,
who used to run Google plus here, who's
now at a company called alive core. Um,
you know,
my dad has afib and he has a little
device on his phone that measures your EKG
and it will tell you whether you're an
atrial fibrillation. Like, that's amazing.
It's totally amazing.
Like you don't have to go in it.
Like you can get instant
real time information.
We are on the beach in Hawaii
and he's like, oh, I'm an
a fib. Um, like it's, it's,
so it's utterly amazing.
And I think that there is,
um,
there's genuinely a world that is coming
where you're going to be able to get a
lot of your healthcare on your phone and
is it taking a picture of your mole and
then it in and you can
get multiple opinions.
Is it someone like grand rounds where
you get multiple opinions online?
Like there's,
there's like one of,
one of the things I'm really hopeful for
is that healthcare becomes less about
the art of medicine and much more data
driven where you get some, you know,
a number of people, a number of
opinions looking at a case. And, um,
and you can have like, again,
on the thing like a mole,
you can really apply machine learning
to that. And so what are ways,
like I see a whole new world
that is really cropping up. Um,
and whether it's going to be, you know,
some kind of Chat Bot that's telemedicine.
Like there's a lot that's happening there.
So when I think about 23 and me's role,
I think that we become the hub and a
large part like we are like your genetic
information is the core. It's like
the genetic code of you. It's, it is,
it's like it's the digital
representation of you. And so we're the,
we're the epicenter of it and then helping
you figure out all the different ways
that you can navigate that information
and what can you do with that information.
And we can't do that alone.
Like that's where we need partners.
Like I need ways that you
could potentially analyze
your blood at home instantly
or that you could get, you
know, you could, you know,
take a picture of your mole and have it
analyzed like a whole way that you can
actually start to think about measuring
yourself at home. Not In like,
like the quantified self movement is,
is more extreme,
but like ways like the average individual
wants to just like be healthy and
proactive. So I think that there's
a whole new world that is coming up,
which is almost virtual healthcare.
And I think the brick and mortar is,
um, you know, we'll always have hospitals
and we'll always have brick and mortar,
but, um, you know, the same way.
There's blockbusters out there. So, um,
there's not a lot. Um, and I think that
more and more you're going to see that.
Like,
I don't think that you doctor's visits
are going to be very different in the
future. And I think that's where, um,
my hope is like the research that 23 and
me can do is that we will make a number
of discoveries about, you know, what does,
what is the meaning of a genetic
information and then also what are really
meaningful ways that you can
prevent. And, and that's like,
when I think about my ultimate
success, it's, you know, I
would like to have cures.
I'd love to have a cure for
Parkinson's and other diseases.
And that is a high priority
and we're fucking on that. Um,
but I'd also love to be able
to tell a 20 year old like,
this is what you need to do to be able
to live, to be healthy at a hundred. And,
and to me that's like,
that's, that's real success.
So it was kind of goes into
life extension, life extension.
I'm excited. It's like it's, it's again,
there's a lot of silicon valley discussion
of like, Oh I want to live to a 500.
Um,
I think it's like my goal is like very
like I would just like to be healthy at a
hundred. Um, like when I
read stories about, you know,
like a hundred year olds
running the marathons and
like doing things like that's
what you want to do. I don't want
to be like in a critical care unit,
like supported at a hundred.
Like, no, I want to be healthy.
Like I don't want to be diabetic and
have congestive heart disease. Like no,
like just let me be healthy.
And tell me how, and again,
it goes back to this like mantra of like
health is what you do every single day.
Like I dress like this because
like I'm, I'm Googley. Um,
but also because I exercise all the
time, like I biked here, I'll bike back,
I'll bike home.
Like I'm always like,
I love to humiliate people in the office
when they take the elevator. I'm like,
why? Like why would you do that? Why
would he do it in front of me too? Um,
so I think it's really important to like
get some of those types of messages out.
Excellent. Um, so now we're going
to go to audience questions.
So if anyone has a question,
please head over to the mic.
There's a mic right there.
You can just,
yeah,
when a check for online questions
too. Okay. You hear me? Hi,
I'm Dina on their went,
when they go to the doctor within
23 and me report the doctor,
typically the tell me
something like, hey, why,
why do you need these as I
did something wrong. Now,
why do you do have the d without
asking a doctor first hand? So my,
one of my [inaudible] is if you're
doing something to educate them in that
sense.
And also when I see them,
the possibilities to get a disease,
they are all taking into account,
compare it with a m people,
coca sick people in Europe
because most researchers,
but I'm from Latin America, so I don't
feel represented. I know that my,
my question is if we're going to do
Samson to have more samples from that
region. Yeah. So like I know that my test,
the results are more accuracy and
also for something or Santina you,
you don't have that. I mean, you can't use
20:00 PM. You have to come here. Right.
So,
yeah. So first question on physicians
and second on International. Um,
so physicians are definitely the
last mile. Like it's painful for us.
And um,
and it's disappointing to me because
we get a lot of people who take their
reports to physicians and the physician
says, oh, this is not worthwhile. Um,
so you're not alone in that.
And we've tried some initiatives
and the early initiatives to,
to work with an educate doctors.
And I always joke if I took a thousand
kits to Stanford shopping center and I
was like, these are free, they
would be gone in five minutes. Um,
if I took a thousand kits to asco,
the big oncology meeting,
I would come home with 990 of them.
Um,
like we've literally tried to give away
kits to doctors and they're like, oh no.
Um,
so there's a huge,
there's a lot of work that we have to
do to engage the medical community.
Um, one thing that I have
found is that there's like,
there's a new crop of physicians,
like a lot of doctors who are
online and the telemedicine,
and it's something that we're thinking
about is how do we cultivate the
physicians who are trying to embrace
a world of prevention and like,
what could you do with this? And it's,
it's hard because like, it's not,
it's not a big reimbursements.
Like any way you can go to
any dermatologist and get
botox like today in the
next hour. And if you said, I want to
get a mole check, they'll be like, oh,
in October I have time at nine. Um, so,
and that's because a mole check doesn't
reimburse, but botox botoxes you know,
$300 in 15 minutes. So, um,
so I think that's where like we have
a lot to do to try to work with the
physician world. We're
hiring someone. Like that's,
that's like a big initiative for me on
the team is how do we engage the medical
world. Um, second on international,
the same way we had
regulatory issues here.
The rest of the world is pretty
complicated and there's a lot of
misunderstanding about genetics.
Um,
so each country has laws about how to
enter into those countries and they're
pretty complicated. It's almost
like we just haven't had, like,
I think a lot of startups fail because
they try to do too much, too early.
So we think about international
and honestly, like again,
going back to the love of hacks,
one of the ways I thought about
just hacking it is just like,
just be in like JFK in Miami and like
tried it because then you can actually
pull a lot of diversity in
without necessarily having
so or like in the reality
is like the u s is this like
beautiful melting pot where if I want,
you know, instead of going into
China, which is really complicated,
like I can go to San Francisco.
And so like for me,
part of it is making sure that we're
recruiting the right populations.
And so we are looking specifically
at targeting different groups.
Like we have a big African American
initiative. Um, you know, we have a, uh,
a whole global initiative
of like countries where
we're trying to get specific
populations, um, both for
the ancestry testing so that
we can improve our product.
But also then for having the
diversity in health research.
So I'm going to take it online question,
who owns the Ip produced
from an individual's geno
typing data when they use 23
and me. So there's no IP in
that capacity. So like if you,
you own what happens, like if
you spit, you own your data, um,
if you consent for research, you're
consenting to be part of this aggregate.
So for instance, of I discover
that um, you know, here's a gym,
like I talk about 400,000 people
participated in the depression study.
And so, um, there's not IP on, on genes,
so we're not filing patents for instance,
on like,
Oh this genetic association is part
of parking of you know, depression.
So there's no IP on that.
We might say, oh this, this,
this mutation looks like
it's potentially in a,
in an area where it's
potentially druggable we then
make a small molecule or an
antibody and we're going to target that.
That is rip because like in some ways
it's so far down stream from everything.
Our hope is like we are publishing
and putting out into the public world,
like all of the genetic
associations that we're finding.
So we'd like to publish a lot. We have
over 100 publications out there. Um,
but we really look at like
the longterm downstream.
Like we're owning that Ip because
we're putting in like, again,
what's going to end up being hundreds of
millions of dollars of work into trying
to make successful
shall be curious. Right. Man, thank you
so much for coming. I'm really inspired.
I'm no good.
I'm think Google doodles pm I wanted to
ask about how you attract and retain so
many women I have from everyone
and I talked to in your company,
they're so happy. They're, how do
you do it? Especially now really,
especially now that so many
women are feeling like they're,
they can stay in tech.
Her,
I um, you know, we had a
problem for a while where, um,
we were like,
we were trying really hard to hire a
man for the management team and it was
like, man, there were looking for
a head of engineering at one point.
I remember we just like, we had this woman
and we're like, no, no, no, we need a man.
Like we need Wiley's one. Um, so I think,
um, I mean I think it's
like all aspects of diverse.
Like I think we've tried really hard
to have a supportive environment.
And for me, like I've worked,
I always had, I was like,
I've worked for really bad people.
I worked for like some really
complicated funds. Like I was like,
who in the room has
anyone who's been in jail?
Like I have bosses who have been in jail.
So like I've worked for like some
really, um, challenging individuals.
So I know what it's like. Um, and
I'm trying to do the exact opposite.
Like the first job I ever had, um,
the Wallenberg family in Sweden,
they were amazing. Like, I've never,
like, they treated me so well,
so I know what it's like to have
a bad job in a bad environment.
I know what it's like to have a great
environment. And in Sweden for instance,
like this woman showed up one day and I
was like, who are you? And she was like,
oh, I'm newly promoted partner. I've
been on maternity leave for two years.
And I was like, what? Um, so it, like,
it was one of those things like
culturally it's set to me like,
here's a group of people,
the Walmart,
like who promoted this woman who's like
been on maternity leave for two years.
It was amazing.
And so I really try to create a culture
where we support people through their
lifecycle. And um, you know,
a lot of people have been at the company
who they get married, they've had kids,
they get divorced.
Like,
like there's a whole lifecycle and
not everyone is awesome every day.
And so like you can be awesome for a while
and then you have a kid and it's like,
and the kid sick for a while and
you have take off time. Like,
I can't be the asshole boss. It's like, oh
my God, you're out. Um, like I have like,
I have to support people and I look
at people for the psalm of like,
I hope people stay for 10 years and I
look at people for the song. But like,
what can you,
can you contribute in that in that period?
And like how do we also support you?
Um,
we're really very much like
your family is your family,
but like we're your family away from home.
And so like I have to support people in
a good way and I have to listen. Um, and,
and I think it's like
there's a level of humility.
Like the number one thing we
have for hiring is humility.
Like you need really smart people,
but like I just,
the culturally like you gotta fit in
with the humility and we have to support
people.
Paul,
thank you. Welcome. Hey,
thanks for doing this. Of course. Um,
so I know there might be some liabilities
associated with the idea I'm about to
mention,
but is there some time when this would
be an opportunity finding tool as well,
that your DNA seems like you would be
perfect for pole vaulting? So, you know,
practical that we do.
Um,
you know, I don't know if we'll ever
get down to those types of specifics.
Like I think, um, um, you know,
I think that there's like for sprinting,
you know,
there's genetic variants associated with
like, do you have the double twitch? Um,
will it ever refine enough to be
able to say like, Oh, you know,
you're really great at this
specific sport. I think, again,
it goes back to the world of genes
and environment. Like you, you,
you need passion to be great at anything
you need passion. Like the, the,
the most important aspect for me out of
that movie Gattica was that this guy has
a genetic, like he's genetically not
likely to survive for some reason,
but he has the passion and like
passionate counts for so much. Um,
so I think without a doubt you'll
hear things like if you are,
we did some research at
one point on, um, um,
and like being toned down or like
having a, a musical ear and you know,
you could imagine at some point like,
would you say, okay, like, hey, you know,
you're just not like you just,
if you want to be a pianist,
you're going to have to work that much
harder. So I think it's, you know,
and we're like, we did a study for
them since in weight loss. Like we,
my hope one day is to be able to
say, if you're overweight, you,
it's only gonna take you four
weeks to lose weight. You,
it's going to take you seven weeks.
Like you're just genetically more likely
to not be able to lose that weight.
And I think that's where it will help
people not say, not know like, oh,
you're not going to be great at this,
but like you just might have to work
harder instead of the famous 10,000 hours.
You need 12,000 hours.
Yeah. Cool. Thank you. Okay.
Hi. Thanks for coming. This is very
interesting. Um, so I was wondering,
I noticed that, I mean, so there's 23 and
me, but there's also lots of other, um,
lots of other sort of
similar con, um, companies.
So if you're looking at sort of
ancestry yeah, you get to Lincoln,
find out your relatives
who are with 23 and me,
but then there's people who
are with other companies.
It seems like everything's kind of siloed.
Have you thought about talking to other
companies and seeing if there are ways
that you can connect across each other's
databases to help people find relatives?
Yeah, I think, um, with other companies,
we did a promotion for instance,
on Dna day where we allow people from
ancestry.com to upload their data. Um,
you know, the companies are
pretty competitive right now,
so there hasn't been any specific
initiative to like try like you can always
download and I think upload.
Um, so, so no, I mean I,
it's,
it's a problem.
Like it's not in the best interest of
customers for sure to not allow, like,
I would think that that would actually
be something that's great. But like,
I think there's a lot of competition
right now, so that hasn't,
that hasn't happened.
Um, but without a doubt,
like we know that people who
are looking for family members,
oftentimes we'll do both services.
Yeah. Okay. So, and, and again,
we might do more in the future.
Um,
and in some ways this goes with some
of the privacy issues like we had. Um,
so again, when you talk about
the goal and say killer,
like one of the things that's important
for us to do from a privacy perspective
is not allow a relative matches
from DNA that's uploaded, right?
Because if you allow that,
then you open up the door for
things like the golden state killer.
And so we had like, for instance, when
we did this promotion with, um, you know,
anyone could upload their
DNA from other places.
We would tell you if there was
someone within your close circle,
but we want to identify who
it is and we did that. So,
and you would have to spit again. And we
did that specifically so that you like,
from a privacy perspective,
we think a lot about privacy.
Cool. Thanks. Okay.
Oh, hi. I'm so sorry. I have some,
my, a spit and then I'd get it back.
And then it tells me about,
um, like my ancestry and uh,
well my health prospects,
um,
say I have like a,
like what would it be like,
is there a way I can prevent myself
from having like cancer in the future?
Like just off of that,
we don't have, so the, the,
the cancer report we have right now
is the breast cancer report that is
associated with, um, typically, you know,
Ashkenazi Jewish descent and um,
and it does have a high
penetration of cancer.
So meaning like those people
are likely to get cancer.
What we found people have done is they
go and they get either mastectomy or they
take out their ovaries. Um, so
there's ways that you can potentially,
like it's extreme to
prevent. Um, you know,
the other thing that's out there
is there are, for instance,
there's people who are genetically
high risk for colon cancer.
And in that capacity,
you know,
right now I think the recommendations
or coal colonoscopies at 45,
in that case you could start having
colonoscopies earlier. So a lot of it,
there's not necessarily
known specifics about, okay,
if you want to prevent cancer, these
are the things that you do. Um,
in every disease area you can say,
you know,
don't smoke exercise and eat better.
And what we find that having something
that is a risk factor in black and white
in your DNA motivates people to
actually do all those things.
But those are the biggest swing factors
you have always as your exercise and
your diet and your environment.
Okay. Thank you. Okay.
Hi,
my name is Yulia and I'm an intern in
Google brain genomics and it looks like
Google is also looking into like
genetics and predicting disease from,
from genetics and also
connected to healthcare. Yeah,
I know that also Microsoft is
looking into healthcare and genetics.
So what do you think about this?
Like,
do you think that you will collaborate
with Google or Microsoft at some point or
your be competitors or 23 minutes so far
ahead in this research that I think so.
I, I've spent a lot of time,
like in, in the early days,
like back when we were starting the
company, like Google, Microsoft,
others like Microsoft had had um, RFPs
out for a while doing genetic research.
They've had a great, you know, they
have, they had a really great team. Um,
you know, Google brain team is
amazing. Um, I know Jeff Dean, well,
like it's an amazing group
of people that are there.
The number one problem in healthcare
I find is nobody has the Dataset.
Like I love going to big data meetings
and everyone's like talking about big
data and I'm like, but you don't have
any data. Like, I mean, it's just,
it's fascinating. I'm like, I'm like,
it's like the emperor has no clothes.
People like, there's not a
lot of data out there. So,
I mean there's some of
these big initiatives and my
whole goal was like I want
the data like 23 and me's initial premise.
I was like,
you need to generate the data first.
And so the number one thing that we
have is we have a massive living dataset
where when I can go back to my customers
and say, okay, do you have migraines?
Can you tell me more information?
And for those customers who want to
participate, they can tell me more.
And so it's,
it's one of the things like there's the
UK biobank and there's all these other
biobanks out there,
but they're static.
Like we did this project with this one
group in the UK and I requested sample,
it was a recontact double database.
I requested samples.
Three years later they called me and
they're like, we have the samples.
I was like, who are you? Like
what is, I was like, oh yeah,
like that's their definition or be
contactable like in this world of the
Internet age, like just text me or
like send me a message like habit,
like show up as an alert on my phone.
So that's the main thing, like the, the,
the key that we created.
I needed to first create the data
before I can solve the problems.
There's amazing people out there
who can solve the problems,
but it's really hard.
There's no one else out there who
has the amount of data we have.
We'd love to like, and they
said, we, I know Jeff Dean,
I know that team. While if,
you know Lizzy, like all,
like we love that team.
We're always open to working
or just join us. Like
another question, last question. Okay. So,
um, so I said that 23 and me's
hiring machine learning specialists.
So do we check,
send does 23 and me use machine learning
or is it mostly looking into literature
and see what you, which variant is
connected to each disease from literature?
So we do a lot.
We have a pipeline where we're doing
our own genome wide association studies
quite a bit. We are starting to do
a fair amount of machine learning,
um, and thinking about, so for instance,
like one of the first
applications probably is an
ancestry and helping people in
predicting ancestry.
Um,
we have a number of initiatives in house
and those are the types of things we
thought of. But like, again, with, with
all of, with all of the data that we have,
we're, we're right for all
those technologies now. Like,
like all the applications.
So again, my job is like being
somebody who's not technical is like,
I'm trying to create first like this
massive enthusiasm from the world to
participate in research and like,
to learn about their genetics and then
create data that has like the highest,
the data quality that we
need to do that research.
And then to empower everybody with all
the different techniques and skills like
to then analyze the data and what
can we do with it. Thank you. Okay.
Well, Ann, thank you
very much for joining us.
[inaudible].